[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
paragliding in breath of the wild was
pretty awesome not only did it make
going from point a to point b faster and
more fun to do but it also encourages
the player to make more use of the
climbing ability reaching high vantage
points gave the player a way to get more
air time to glide further while at the
same time making discoveries in the
overworld easier and more intuitive it
truly was a freeing experience gone were
the days of so-called bethesda mountain
climbing being allowed to climb in
designated spots only or relying on
mounts or late-game vehicles now we had
most of the tools for limitless
traversal available from pretty much the
very beginning because of these two
mobility options climbing and
paragliding nintendo went out of its way
to differentiate the game from the
established formula by calling it open
air rather than the traditional open
world but as i've mentioned in previous
videos the air or sky itself wasn't
actually utilized all that much in
breath of the wild with the exception of
some scripted events enemies even the
ones that fly are mostly confined to
ground level within reach of the bow the
sky is a safe and effective way to get
where you want to go but all the action
and discoveries are still mostly found
down on the surface it seems that for
the sequel nintendo wants to truly do
justice to the open-air name and take
traversal and exploration to new heights
to the clouds to be exact it goes
without saying that a setting like this
will require new types of mobility and
that is exactly what we find in the new
gameplay patents published in december
of last year out of all three mechanics
featured in these patents this one is
probably the least groundbreaking from a
game design perspective but at the same
time i would argue that it's also the
most necessary inclusion after all the
sky was by far the biggest focal point
of the second teaser so it's likely
gonna play a prominent role if the sky
isn't fun to traverse and explore it'll
significantly hurt the game's experience
as such in this video i will explain in
detail what link's new aerial mobility
will be based on the information inside
the patent itself this will include the
different movement options how they work
as well as the controls and camera
positions during the execution so here
we go
one of the first things we noticed in
the teaser aside from the sky itself
it's in the sky was the way link was
falling facing down arms outstretched in
a similar way to that of a skydiver a
pose also known as the arch for many of
us this was of course an immediate
callback to skyward sword a game which
also featured sky traversal and a
similar way of free falling when
dropping down from great heights this
opening shot is the only footage we have
of link in freefall so prior to the
publication of the patents we had no
idea if there was more to it than this
turns out there is the description and
illustrations clarify that link will be
able to descend in 5 different ways
normal falling low velocity falling
diving falling backward falling and high
velocity falling each one of these has
its own type of pose attributed to it of
course normal falling and low velocity
falling we already know from the first
game falling in an upright position arms
slightly raised to the side and drifting
down slowly with the paraglider the
other three are new to the sequel diving
falling is the aforementioned pose we
saw in the teaser as well as in skyward
sword backward falling is similar except
facing up instead of down and high
velocity falling sees link almost
completely upside down facing the
surface arms tucked to his side this one
is quite similar to skyward sword as
well where link could speed up his fall
by pressing forward and speaking of
which here too does each type of body
position come with its own speed
naturally drifting down with the
paraglider is the slowest after that we
have the diving and backward pose which
have the same falling speed normal
falling is slightly faster seeing as you
have less air resistance in an upright
position and needless to say high
velocity falling is the fastest since
your body is even more aerodynamic when
upside down and you don't have your arms
out according to the text the character
can transition between these poses in
two main ways the first is executed
while link is falling regularly and the
second involves a special action which
in the examples given is demonstrated by
the use of the bow during a regular fall
i.e when link is not performing any
other actions while in the air you can
transition between poses by pressing and
sometimes holding down specific buttons
and the inputs for these are actually
mentioned inside the patent though do
keep in mind that these might not be
final and subject to change for the
finished game deploying the paraglider
will once again work the same way as it
did in the original by pressing x while
airborne and pressing b will cancel the
paraglider and link will resume his fall
the player can shift into the diving
pose either by pressing r or tilting the
left control stick upward this can be
triggered not only from a normal fall
but according to the text you can even
go straight into a dive from low
velocity falling as well in other words
while paragliding instead of pressing b
to cancel it you can press r instead and
you'll go straight from gliding into a
diving pose backward falling can only be
accessed from a dive or from high
velocity this is also referred to as a
turnaround instruction pressing a while
diving will turn link around and face in
the other direction which in this case
causes him to transition into a backward
fall and pressing a again will revert
him back to his original orientation
it's as simple as that high velocity
falling is done by pressing and holding
r while either diving or backwards
falling for as long as the button is
held down the character will fall at the
highest speed possible and releasing it
will slow him back down again back into
a dive as you can see there are some
small restrictions when it comes to
which type of pose you can access from
the other and this illustration gives a
good overview of this notice that while
paragliding you can transition into a
normal fall or a dive but not straight
into high velocity or backward falling
meaning you'll have to switch to a dive
first before you can access the other
two similarly you can also not pull out
the paraglider while falling at high
velocity
each pose also comes with its own pros
and cons an example being the amount of
freedom of movement you'll have
obviously paragliding has the lowest
vertical speed but you can travel the
fastest and furthest horizontally diving
has significantly less horizontal speed
than the paraglider but actually does
give you more range of movement when it
comes to steering in all directions
including backwards which was very slow
with the paraglider and because high
velocity falling has the fastest
vertical speed you also won't be able to
steer link nearly as much horizontally
making precise landings during this pose
less than ideal the description also
states that the camera will react
automatically and accordingly when
switching between poses for instance
when going into a dive the camera will
automatically snap into a downward
facing position above the character
giving you a clear view of the surface
below turning around into a backward
fall will make the camera move on its
own into an upward facing position right
below link so you can see what's above
you according to the description this
will make it easier for the player to
reorient themselves and get a sense of
direction which is definitely a good
thing if you got nothing but clouds
around you i can imagine losing track of
what's up and down sometimes if the
camera never reacts to the changes in
position and orientation after the
camera has snapped into position it'll
most likely relinquish control back to
the player and we'll be free to orient
the camera in any direction we please
this would already be a huge improvement
over skyward sword even in the hd
version which does have a free cam you
have zero control over the camera while
skydiving no way to freely look around
and see what's above or behind you for
instance you do have one trigger to look
below you but only on your loft wing and
of course you couldn't even deploy your
parasail until the game told you to
which was usually at the last minute
only a few feet off the ground it really
seems like breath to a2 will greatly
expand upon the limitations of this game
when it comes to the freedom of movement
and control when skybound one last thing
to mention about the transitions between
the different types of falling is that
there are bound to be more special
operations and exceptions for instance
the description mentions that if link
simply walks or falls off the edge of an
object high in the sky one of the
islands for instance he will simply fall
down as normal and the player will have
to transition into a dive or the
paraglider manually however it also says
that if you perform a jump right as
you're about to go over the edge you'll
automatically go straight into a dive
instead we already saw something akin to
this in the original performing a jump
above water for example would
automatically trigger link to dive
whereas if you just walk off the edge he
falls down normally so i'm guessing it
will work similar to that but like i
said there's bound to be exceptions as
well if link jumps from say the roof of
a house close to ground level the game
probably won't force him into a dive and
make him fall flat on his face though
that would be funny
this brings us to the second method
which is unique to special actions like
i said in the descriptions and
illustrations it mainly focuses on the
bow but at the very end it does also
mention shooting a gun an action of
throwing an object like a weapon or
emitting a fireball by magic oh sorry a
magic the cool thing about this method
is that here the player doesn't have to
control link's pose manually instead
it's all done automatically depending on
the angle of your aim if you aim all the
way straight up link's posture will be
changed to a backward fall move the
cursor down and he will slowly
transition into an upside down position
there's essentially radial boundaries
that dictate when this change in posture
has to take place and you might also
notice that these boundaries overlap and
there's a reason for this this is to
prevent unnatural movement animation if
there was only one set boundary between
each pose right here for example and you
would move the cursor right across the
boundary and back again link would
constantly be shifting between two poses
which again would look funny but not
exactly be practical instead each pose
has its own set boundaries and they will
reset every time link moves into a new
position this system will allow us to
have a lot more range and hints that the
game will likely feature some crazy
aerial fight sequences after all why
else includes such an elaborate aiming
mechanic into the game if an enemy
approaches you from above you'll be able
to first turn around giving you a clear
view of the enemy and then drawing your
bow to get a shot if the enemy shifts
this position suddenly you won't have to
worry about changing link's orientation
instead it's all done automatically as
long as you have the bow out and putting
away the bow will likely cause link to
resume the falling position he last
assumed while aiming now what about
bullet time you know that immensely
helpful mechanic from breath of the wild
that wasn't in any zelda game before
well the description says that it does
still exist similar to the original
objects enemies and projectiles will
still be slowed down by a factor of 10
and it'll still consume stamina the only
thing i'm not sure of is what happens
when link completely runs out of stamina
in one instance it mentions that when
link runs out he will transition into a
normal fall however it also says that
paragliding still consumes stamina as
well so say you run out while you're
somewhere high up in the sky i doubt
that would mean that link would just
continue to fall down helplessly for
minutes on end until finally crash
landing down on the surface that would
be a pretty severe punishment for such a
simple mistake especially since bullet
time drains stamina pretty damn quickly
and some fights might go on for a long
time in breath of the wild when you ran
out of stamina mid-flight link would
also fall down and while falling your
stamina doesn't fill back up again until
you touch solid ground so i'd imagine
that in the sequel they have to do it a
bit differently and i'm guessing that
during a normal fall your stamina does
fill back up again and well that's about
it for this one it's not as complex as
the other two mechanics and doesn't
require much more explanation i'm just
happy to see something like this added
to breath of the wild's already amazing
mobility options i can only imagine what
kind of crazy stuff we'll see in the sky
the type of enemies boss battles maybe
and who knows maybe there will be even
more additions to traverse the sky
besides free falling and paragliding
even more new powers grappling hooks
flying vehicles loftwings the
possibilities are endless and even with
these patents it's likely that we
haven't even seen five percent of what
we'll be able to do in the game and with
that we have covered every mechanic
featured inside the patents if you
missed the other two there will be a
link in the description as well as the
end card thank you so much for sticking
by with me on this one a special thanks
to you for watching to my discord
community mods and of course my channel
members and patreons a big thanks to
kanuki and dimash for joining and to
merlin stephen and parker and william
morales for rejoining welcome and
welcome back you guys are the best and
that is all for now this is don signing
off and
have a good one
so
[Music]
you